[Music]
it is time for this week's pet project
lori herron joins us from nspca
and she brought along someone who needs
a safe and caring home
a cat named kiwi hi lori tell us tell us
all about kiwi
hey jc this is kiwi and i want to talk
about kiwi but i also want to talk about
an event
on saturday in which you can see kiwi or
should i say
namaste because the event is kidney cat
yoga
at the happy earth market this saturday
between noon and 1
and kiwi is going to be there along with
some of our other cats that we call our
kidney cats
they are wonderful cats that are in the
early stages of kidney disease so
they take some extra loving care kiwi
here is an
eight-year-old beautiful calico girl she
is
um a kidney cat she does require a
special diet
and we can talk to you more about sub-q
fluids which is something
she would require as well her front paws
are declawed now of course we don't do
that at nevada svca and
we do not recommend it for a variety of
reasons but she was already declawed
when she came to us she was a transfer
from another local
rescue organization you can see jc that
kiwi is a love bug she is
all curled up in my lap so for those of
you who are
watching and want a lap cat to sit
inside with
during all of these storms kiwi would be
the perfect companion
kiwi looks adorable and lori my parents
are actually inspired by watching the
segment every week and they're getting
ready to adopt a cat
what would you tell a first-time cat
owner who's about to bring in a cat to
their house
so cats are very different from dogs
there are um
i personally adore cats for a first time
cat owner
you need to know that they can be more
independent than dogs
they don't always come when you call
them they do bite and scratch that kind
of comes with the territory
and depending on the cat sometimes they
can have
a little cattitude but some of my
favorite cats out there have catitude
just as long as they're not expecting a
dog and there's lots of information i'm
sure that
um feel free to have um i think it's
george i don't know what your mom's name
is hey you know the world
you have them call me you have the
number i will and i'm happy to talk to
them about cats
we'll do lori thank you so much we
appreciate the event it's gonna be
fantastic this weekend
and if you're interested in adopting a
pet go to nevadaspca.org they have
information about the event there as
well
or call them at 702-873-7722